[Music]
so george 30 years ago when i started
teaching this stuff i was first teaching
people how to get out of debt
live on a budget
be generous
live on less than you make so you have a
plan you avoid debt you save money for
emergencies and later for investing
and all of those principles work but
people kept saying which one do i do
first
and so i started laying out well you
should do this first and that first you
should have an emergency fund before you
start your 401k
and uh
then i figured out it's easier to have
an emergency fund if you don't have any
payments
and so you need to get out of debt first
because of course i learned my lesson
the hard way going bankrupt and getting
out of debt and
learning how important it was to be debt
free as a process as a part of building
wealth
so all of that started to formulate
after a few years of teaching
in various settings and what became
financial peace university it used to be
called life after debt
and it started becoming what we now call
the baby steps
the interesting thing is that now the
baby steps have gone into
the total money makeover book which has
sold almost 10 million copies
and they have become the proven plan
the shortest distance between where you
are now and wealth
where you are if you live like no one
else later you can live and give like no
one else what is the shortest distance
and we need a path to run on because the
way you eat an elephant it's
overwhelming
do i do
my 401k with the match or my kid's
college
or do i have an emergency fund or do i
pay on this 18 credit card debt or
or or or or and nothing gets done you
get paralysis of the analysis you get
frozen absolutely and this step these
baby steps have worked for me they've
worked for millions and it's really
simple if you do it they work
and it all starts with baby step one
having this foundation saving one
thousand dollars for a starter emergency
fund this is just a small buffer between
you and life before we start tackling
the debt exactly and if you have a
thousand dollars already great just set
that aside that's your baby step one any
money you have that's not retirement
anything you can sell that is not
retirement you're going to liquidate it
if it's not retirement you've got some
stock over here that grandpa left you
you got a gold bar under your bed i
don't know what it is but you got any
money that's above a thousand dollars
maybe you've got ten thousand dollars a
savings account that's nine thousand
dollars you've got that you don't need
past baby step one we're going to put it
all on baby step two and baby step two
is the famous one that's the debt
snowball where you list your debts
smallest to largest you pay minimum
payments on everything but the little
one and you attack the little one with a
vengeance side note baby step one should
not take you more than 30 days
maximum you need to work extra sell some
stuff have a garage sale put the kids on
craigslist whatever you got to do here
let's get it done
and you know we're going to get busted
into this get a thousand bucks quick
baby step two you should be debt free
but your house now you may have to sell
a stupid boat
uh you may have to take an extra job but
most people that have followed the total
money makeover baby steps in financial
peace university
are debt-free inside of two years yeah
and that's with doing it with some
gazelle intensity like you talk about in
financial peace university and once you
pay off all that debt now you've freed
up all those payments right you have
that income about what it'd be like to
have no payments but a house payment
wow we're breathing easy
and then we can move on to baby step
three where we save three to six months
of expenses in a fully funded emergency
fund this is the final buffer where we
say we're never going back into debt
because we are the bank now yep
grandma's rainy day fund why it's gonna
rain dave you need to be positive i'm
positive it's gonna rain
you need to be ready when crap happens
there's a pandemic coming around every
corner there's something coming and if
you have 20 000 cash in the bank three
to six months of expenses whatever it is
and you have no payments
you are the third pig
in the three little pigs the one that's
in the brick house when the big bad wolf
comes you're ready for life you're ready
to go now you're ready to build wealth
but that you just now have gotten up to
ground zero you've just now gotten up to
even
when you have that emergency fund and
you're debt-free now you're ready to
build wealth and baby step four you put
15
of your income
aside into good growth stock mutual
funds in retirement plans start where
there's a match beyond the match always
do roth
and if you've exhausted roth and match
and still are not to 15
then go on to a traditional 401k or ira
but do roths before traditional and do
match before roths
it's mathematically in your favor to do
that up to the fifteen percent don't do
twenty percent don't do eleven percent
do fifteen percent
while you are doing baby steps four
you're also gonna be doing five and six
simultaneously absolutely so baby step
five is where we're saving for our
children's college fund and this is
gonna look different for everyone
there's no set number here because it
really depends on your situation did you
have the baby last week or is the baby
18.
that makes a difference on how much you
need for college right what you got to
do for college it's like is this an oh
crap moment or hey we're going to be
diligent and safe did we wait almost
until too late now they have to go to
college debt-free they cannot
participate in this epic student loan
system failure that is called america
right now it is horrible out there do
not let your kids go in debt you do not
have to go to debt go to community
college for free for two years go go to
in-state school work six jobs get
scholarships our student loan problem is
a parenting problem mom and dad let kids
sign up for crap they couldn't afford
bad mama bad daddy
they gotta have the conversations that's
where it starts and there's a reason you
say baby step four invest for yourself
before the kids because there's a
hundred percent chance you're going to
retire there's a 50 50 chance or less
these days that your kid's going to go
to college and graduate yeah yeah this
is this less than 50 chance they're
going to graduate so
uh
that this is important so while you're
doing 15 percent you do whatever you
need to do for your kids college
whatever you decide to do for your kids
college beyond that if you can find any
money you do that on baby step six and
that's pay off your house
start chunking on the house now when
you're in one through three you are so
intense your friends are freaking out
your grandmother thinks you need
counseling you are gazelle intense like
a gazelle running from a cheetah when
you're in four through seven you're not
intense anymore you are now intentional
you're just doing it on purpose but
you're no longer on beans and rice your
own beans and rice rice and beans
scorched earth on one through three two
you get those three things done
now
get that house paid off the average
person following this stuff is paying
off their home in about seven or eight
years
now
that tells us that the whole program is
taking about 10 years and the average
baby steps millionaire the average
everyday millionaire that we've studied
we're finding them become a millionaire
from the time they start with intensity
followed by intentionality become a
millionaire in about 10 and a half years
yeah 11.2 years 10.6 years are the two
numbers we keep running into
so this is completely possible yeah and
once you pay off that house it's time to
build wealth and give outrageously in
baby step seven that's where it ends
yeah you will be a millionaire shortly
after your home is paid for if you don't
at that moment and and then you continue
to build wealth and you you raise your
generosity and you continue to build
wealth and you raise your generosity and
you enjoy the money that's where it gets
fun
the only three things you can do with
money and you should do all of them at
baby step seven and that's the route
you're going that's where you are that's
who you are
that is the baby steps